il encourt contre Houilles une division
des cartes deux équipes pour un objectif
se qualifier en 8e de finale de la Coupe
des Yvelines après seulement quelques
minutes de jeu les eaux-villois en rose
manque l'ouverture du score sur cette
action
un électrochoc pour les élans courtois
qui évolue en D2 de district ils
prennent le contrôle du jeu et se
procure les meilleurs occasions de cette
première période ils auraient pu se
retrouver en supériorité numérique mais
le gardien de où il ne se fera pas
expulser sur cette action
et récoltera un carton jaune le score la
pose 0 à 0 bon après c'est une décision
de l'arbitre c'est comme ça il faut
l'accepter
pour revenir sur
rouge moi j'ai pas les images donc je
sais pas on s'en sort plutôt bien parce
que ça selon l'interprétation de
certains arbitres si c'est rouge c'est
compréhensible au retour les vestiaires
et l'encours pousse et obtient un
penalty ne sera pas marqué par le numéro
quelques minutes plus tard sur ce centre
le but est refuser aux élans courtois
pour un hors-jeu les bleus et blanc
n'auraient seront pas à marquer c'est
finalement où et qui s'impose grâce à ce
but 1 à 0 ce sera le score final on a vu
que il y avait la place quand même parce
que on a on a bien joué on les a on les
a maintenu dans le dans le jeu on était
à leur niveau et on aurait pu on aurait
pu marquer ce but un match de coupe donc
pas facile aujourd'hui malgré la petite
division d'écart qui est entre les deux
clubs après bon sort le match coupe on
sait très bien que ce soit Coupe de
France coupe peu importe c'est l'état
d'esprit
l'envie déjà de vouloir gagner ce match
là parce que sur un match tout est
possible
les 8e de finale pour où il le prochain
tour de la coupe des Yvelines est
programmé le dimanche 8 janvier 2023 le
tirage au sort aura lieu le 12 décembre
prochain